hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
i'm just checking it on you
just checking it on yet seeing how your
week's going
see now it's [ __ ] going um
both my kids got sick
and my wife got sick and i was just you
know
you know doing all the [ __ ] vitamins
and all of that [ __ ]
trying not to get sick we all got tested
it wasn't [ __ ] cold the usual [ __ ]
right
so um
you know i was laying down in the bed
and my daughter came in
and we were playing around or whatever
and she was coughing all over me so then
yesterday i woke up and i was like ah
[ __ ]
right so i cancelled everything the new
me
the new me
i used to just if i just would continue
i would i would [ __ ] go to the gym
i'd [ __ ] you know
do what you do at the gym you know what
i mean live a double life meet some guy
in the shower
you ever hear those stories
people working at gyms or they come in
there's a [ __ ] married guy jerking
some other guy off
jesus you think you got [ __ ] problems
you checking off some guy
in a gym
because you're secretly [ __ ] gay and
you're actually going home to a wife and
kids i mean that's them that's a [ __ ]
situation
for the life of me i will never
understand i will never understand why
human beings won't let other human
beings be who the [ __ ] they are as long
as they're not hurting anybody
just don't understand it the fact that
someone has to live a [ __ ] life like
that
jesus to the point that somebody then
has to [ __ ] walk in on that
and all they're trying to do is get
their certificate to be a personal
trainer next thing you know they [ __ ]
walk in on some gay porn i mean that's
just you know he didn't sign up for that
um anyway i should just plow through my
day
plow through my [ __ ] yeah people by the
way just let people do what the [ __ ]
they want to do all right as long as
they're not hurting you just [ __ ]
relax okay
there's a lot of
you know just morons out there
this is how i live my life so you should
live it that way too i don't i'm not
like you
jesus doesn't like you as much as he
likes me then
jesus likes me best the son of the god
had made everything
and just let it run awhile
it's never come back to check in to see
how the [ __ ] we're doing
the son of that guy
likes me better than you
jesus likes me better
cause i got a bass boat and i'm white um
all right
so i [ __ ] stayed in bed
i tried to stay in bed but i have a
[ __ ] you know i have a wife so you
know they don't let you do that [ __ ] you
know you never realize how much of a
[ __ ] butler you are in your own house
until you're trying until you're sick
you know
dude your wife doesn't give a [ __ ] if
they're sick or whatever you gotta
[ __ ] do i'm [ __ ] go i go look i'm
i'm i'm feeling it coming on i'm trying
to fight it off i canceled my show
tonight i feel like if i just lay down i
take this i drink a bunch of water i can
fight this [ __ ] thing off which is
what i did listen to me listen how
[ __ ] strong i sound today
so i'm laying there in bed god for
[ __ ] bit
god for [ __ ] bid i lay down
you know
and [ __ ] chill out i'm [ __ ]
chilling out my lovely wife i love her
to death right
she calls me up i'm like hello laying in
bed she goes hi i'm coming up i'm coming
down the street
i got you got your son in the car and
some bags can you come outside and help
and i wanted to be like well didn't i
tell you that i was sick
in bed and i'm trying not to get sick
then you know what they do then they
make
you know i already told that she knew
that that's what i was doing but then if
i say that in that moment you know what
reaction you get you get
oh okay
fine i was
just asking
and then then they hit it back over to
you now it's on your side of the net the
fact you're sick and you need to [ __ ]
rest is somehow
you're doing something wrong
so i didn't say anything
i gave her a passive aggressive
i said yes but i said it angrily can he
come downstairs help with the packages
he said i was like yeah
it's not like i'm not up here [ __ ]
trying not to get sick or anything
just out of curiosity how did you get my
son in the packages in the car to begin
with
are you low on battery life
the amount of [ __ ] times i pull into
the driveway with one of both the kids
in [ __ ] packages
i just make two trips
right
my wife isn't even sick do i get credit
for that [ __ ] no
huh do i get any extra stamps
down at the video store so i can rent
[ __ ] uh scent of a woman
for [ __ ] 1.99 a day back in the day
at the old blockbuster no i do not i
don't get any credit
i got nothing
you know what
my wife's a hot [ __ ] so i'm gonna give a
[ __ ] about that
i'm gonna do i'm gonna go down to some
one of these [ __ ] antique stores and
i'm gonna buy one of those old-fashioned
bells isn't that what those [ __ ]
broads used to do they would ring a bell
and then the [ __ ] guy would come up
the stairs
right the old bugs bunny cartoons
yes ma'am uh what is it that you totally
have the physical capability of doing
yourself but you'd rather have me do it
because you don't want to leave the
bedroom
what what is it that you would like me
to do
you know i [ __ ] crushed it this
morning i woke up oh do do do and i felt
much better all right
i came downstairs
i made everybody breakfast
everybody bing bang boom
i did my daughter's hair before school
right combed it out parted it down the
middle
a couple two ponytails
crushed that came back did all the
[ __ ] dishes
wiped down the counter did all of that
[ __ ]
all of that [ __ ]
did i get an atta boy [ __ ] no
oh it's a brilliant strategy because
then if you bring it up well i did this
this this and this i know and i
appreciate that
why are you yelling
ah well what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do [ __ ] about it on
your podcast and go right back to doing
what the [ __ ] you were doing anyway
um
so
yeah i'm psyched i'm back in the gym
and uh i'm still eating like a pregnant
woman though i gotta knock that out
you know last night i had a great time
uh
my wife had a friend over and we would
watch it survivor and [ __ ] we had a good
time doing that but i you know
like the dinner was good but then she
bought some sweets and [ __ ] and i just
sat there like a [ __ ] crackhead
just munching down these molasses seized
candy's things and i just was like what
am i doing
in the end i like i haven't felt that
sick since like halloween when i was a
kid
like why am i doing this to myself
and i realized it's like you know what i
do because you're [ __ ] stressed
because you've been working a lot
and you need some days off and you
really don't have any coming up
so rather than rearrange your schedule
so it's more healthier what you do is
you sit down and watch a reality show
and shove half a box of candy down your
throat
this makes it better
stupid
then what you do you wake up the next
morning the first thing you do is you
rub your stomach and you're just like oh
jesus christ what did i do
you know
if i don't eat until friday
maybe i can undo what the [ __ ] i just
did no i'm gonna go to the gym
i'm gonna go to the gym
um
i watched a little bit of the uh
oh i got through the last season uh
season four of the untouchables
which then immediately went right back
around
uh heroes and icons channel
goes right back around
to the pilot episode episode one two
three and four so it was episode 29 and
30 of the fourth season
oh dude you just seen this one they have
in the fourth season the giant killer
like hollywood had such a prejudiced
about like you know what they've done
like a zillion things about like women
and people of color and all of that but
like i don't think there's enough out
there about just their their
their sort of two-minute minor
uh prejudices rather than their game as
conduct ones um
they had a prejudice against really tall
people like just in general society did
they just thought they were big dumb
stupid [ __ ] people right so
this guy's playing he's a great actor
he's playing this giant you know
bodyguard for his boss
and his boss gets shot he's trying to
find out
who did it and he just [ __ ]
manhandles this woman like it's very
frankenstein like part the way they
wrote it well in the end his basket dies
and this guy he's like in this warehouse
hideout and his boss dies and the giant
freaks out and starts like literally
beating up the warehouse
and he's just screaming who's gonna tell
me what to do
oh
who's gonna tell me what to do
because he's really tall which means
he's stupid and they just had him like
childlike and not understanding like his
own strength it was like [ __ ] uh i
when i was watching it going like
because i i know like back in the day
like if you worked out
a lot
the very
uh beginning of bodybuilding
like people thought that you were dumb
there was all of that people thought if
you were an athlete you were dumb
there's still a lot of that too
to this day you know especially with
like feminists when they talk about
guys in sports they just make them all
out to be
morons or they say rape culture they
just you know there's nothing about
you know
all the great things about sports
um
they kind of you avoid that but you know
that's what feminists do right
when they talk about men it's like have
we ever done anything good um
anything at all that you like anything
any this whole wide array of [ __ ] that
we've done you know you like that
[ __ ] bridge you wrote over this
morning wherever the [ __ ] people
leveraged six peop six men died a day
when they were building the [ __ ]
thing
huh
all right they're [ __ ] hairy legs why
don't you why don't you relax count your
blessings every once in a while and then
you can start nitpicking how about a
[ __ ] atta boy
why can't feminists start their meetings
like that okay before we get started
you know to all the men so you actually
hear what we have to say we just want to
say thanks for making most of the stuff
before we start saying the things that
women invented we could we could
probably be mature enough to say by the
way
thanks for most of the stuff
because i can tell you right now if they
made most of the stuff and we came back
around going oh yeah you know the coat
hanger that was us they'd be like oh who
gives the [ __ ]
oh wait i think men do that i think we
do that i don't know
you know i really hate when i do that i
was just checking to see how much time
i'd done and i accidentally shut the
[ __ ] thing off now i gotta
i have to splice two of them together
which basically means all i have to do
is just to hit two extra
keys on the keypad so why would that
upset me
why would that upset me
you notice is
i wake up in the morning
and there's a panic sometimes
you know that panic your wife can have
in her voice like
do you have anything scheduled today
like that's how you wake up
do you have to do your podcast
i do why what's the matter
ah because you know i was just trying to
figure out the day oh jesus christ well
did why did you come with that energy
you just gave me a little heart attack
i didn't come with any energy
what are you talking about jesus
all right let's get off this [ __ ]
subject um how about those red sox
everybody
wrong song
this weekend
[Music]
now if you go back in my podcast why
would you but if you did
you'd
realize all right
that billy redface called this
when the yankees were [ __ ] couldn't
lose
and the red sox couldn't win
the yankees were all of a sudden in
second place
and the red sox were fading
what did your favorite bald ginger what
did he say back in [ __ ] august i said
we're gonna be there because we're not
we're playing the dregs of the league
for the rest of the year
and now look at us we're back into
second place we're a half a game up on
the
yankees the one game [ __ ] playoff
that baseball needs
i'll tell you right now when if if the
whole if most of the league isn't on
steroids
the only thing that keeps people
watching
is a nice good old-fashioned red sox
yankees playoff series so this is going
to be great for baseball
um i'm hoping it's going to be a
one-game playoff because um
you know chris sale is only going five
innings this is supposed to be the rehab
year
which is when i'm excited because we
weren't supposed to be in this position
but you know
playing the yankees i want to win
because i know those they're [ __ ]
stupid fans they'll be like no we're
dead [ __ ] always there we beat you
like they didn't even win like a world
they don't even realize how far they've
fallen
um yeah we finally fought that day
it's just like yeah we're injured this
year no it doesn't matter if i could
dial it [ __ ]
then they lose the next round
yeah but we beat you guys
and it's just like i thought that you
guys only accepted a world series
championship
what happened to that stand i am in such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] mood i need to go to cvs
and buy a big box of [ __ ] kota why am
i [ __ ] on yankee fans
why am i anticipating
the red sox losing you know why because
i don't feel 100
i'm getting over this [ __ ] cold and i
want to go to the gym but i can't
because then i'll get the [ __ ] cold i
probably won't but then i may be the guy
who comes to the gym with half a [ __ ]
cold
well i am wearing a mask
you know this is one one person at the
gym i see right
she gets on the treadmill or the
elliptical
and she has her mask and then what she
does is she has it on and then she folds
it up
over her mouth
like nobody can tell that that's what
she's doing
because
she's looking at herself straight on in
the mirror it looks like it's on and if
you stand in the side you can clearly
see what the [ __ ] she's doing
um
anyway what are you gonna do um
oh as announced i have a uh
a double
vinyl album
for this is just for comedy nerds this
is where my act was one two three four
months before i did i recorded paper
tiger
it has
it's a double album one side of one
album has uh
material that never made it to uh paper
tigers so there is some original stuff
and then there's all my other jokes that
you've heard from paper tiger that are
told in a different way i also believe
there's a bit on there about women
announcing football there's a number of
bits on there that are not that didn't
just didn't make the special
so uh that said amoeba records is where
i'm selling that exclusively
and uh i'm doing a signing there tonight
so i will be down there which is another
reason why i got to make sure i wear a
[ __ ] mask here
you got to make sure you got to make
sure you mask it up man
so
let me do uh let me
read the [ __ ] advertising
uh
liquid death everybody oh now here's a
product i can stand behind man liquid
death horror movie
it's almost spooky season and you know
what that means your favorite hardcore
water brand made a horror movie
yes a liquid death horror movie you can
watch dead till death now on amazon
if that isn't the biggest [ __ ] left
turn i've ever seen on a product
you put bottled water
in aluminum cans that can be
recycled like what's that's gonna do for
the environment and all the fishies and
the mammals in the sea is tremendous
and all of a sudden you're making movies
i hope you're gonna keep making the
water in the can i got one right here
you hear it
i'm always drinking this [ __ ] i love it
liquid death merch
but did you know you can now rock their
hardcore merch while quenching your
thirst and saving the environment
that's right you don't want to be the
last one on the bandwagon death to
plastic and murder your thirst give me
that ice cold aluminum can with the
skull i love these [ __ ] things
and i'm telling you the water tastes way
better than in a plastic bottle that's
been sitting in a [ __ ] warehouse for
three years this water is giving me life
why do they call it liquid death uh
why do they call liquid death and these
aluminum tall boys are infinitely
recyclable so they're bringing death to
plastic bottles they literally just they
asked
a question and they never answered it
because it murders your thirst and it's
death to plastic pollution from water
bottles hopefully if everybody starts
drinking this death to plastic liquid
death also donates 10 of profits to help
kill plastic pollution forever i mean
why why wouldn't you get behind
something like that oh it's still going
try to think of something more hardcore
than that spoiler you can't you can see
these pants cans popping up everywhere
liquid death is available at your whole
foods or 7-eleven but you know that's
not all
uh now you can rock liquid death merch
that crazy logo you know and love is now
available on sweatshirts hats and even
license plate holders
is the license plate holder plastic
are you buying back what you did what's
going on here and don't you dare pay for
shipping go to liquiddeth.com
to get free shipping on all the water
and merch that's liquiddeth.com for free
shipping on all water and merch grab
some now at whole foods or 7-eleven now
and totally murder your thirst by the
way
i finally saw that south park the south
park that uh sort of sopa
at soda sopa
now announcing
the residencies at soda sopa the thing
on the on gentrification
um as always
and i watched that um
with my lovely wife
and she laughed her ass off
from the beginning
all the way to the end just
[ __ ] was dying laughing
um
it was awesome man those south park guys
are the [ __ ]
best um
maybe i'll do that
i'll watch another south park with my
wife makes her laugh we get along
instead of having stupid dust up over
nothing all right noom n-o-o-m when it
comes to losing weight there's a lot of
pressure out there to label foods good
or bad but that just creates unnecessary
dilemmas noom
is here to change
how we feel
how we see food with the
psychology-based approach that looks at
what you eat but also how you eat
instead of making you feel great or or
regret
oh guilt instead of making you feel
guilt or regret
jesus christ uh noom empowers you to
keep going not everyone wants to be on a
strict diet i don't do two a days at the
gym i don't or drink questionable teas
instead of trying to cram your life into
someone else's idea of health try noom
new muse is a psychology based approach
to find a healthier balance that yeah
why am i eating that chocolate man
healthier balance that's moldable to
your life and as a result more
sustainable you don't need rules to lose
weight just the knowledge and wisdom to
help you build smarter more sustainable
habits newm's cognitive behavioral
approach helps you unlearn bad habits
and better understand your relationship
with food with noob taking care of your
health is empowering instead of
stress-inducing no need to fear ruining
the whole program
with one off day noom will get you back
on track start building better habits
for healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial at noom.com mmp that's
noom.com
mmp you know i just realized people can
listen to this podcast all around the
world the world the world the world
thickens places where you know
food isn't so readily available like
what does that advertising sound like
there's so much food over there they
need help not being fat yep that's how
it is
all right
by the way i went down a
uh a music rabbit hole
um
the other day because i was watching um
[ __ ] i was on a plane
i was on the plane man
quest hang on a second quest
love
documentary and i watched the quest love
documentary called
summer of soul
and i saw this guy come out and sing
by himself
one more there's always three look at
the light look at the light let's stare
at it
inhale
nothing
there it is all right
so
this guy comes out and he starts singing
mike who the hell is this
guy i've never seen this guy i never
heard of this guy
this guy's really good
turned out it was a man named david uh
david ruffin
who was the uh
i want to say the original lead singer
in the temptations
the original five
and um
he evidently uh after a while he wanted
to be called david ruffin
and the and the temptations
because he saw oh i gotta blow my nose
now god damn it because i'll just keep
talking as i walk away from the
microphone here basically
because i'm not gonna hit pause and [ __ ]
it up again and have to [ __ ]
edit nine goddamn things together
listen to me listen to how i sound would
you would you ask me to come downstairs
and get some [ __ ] packages out of a
car
um
anyway
what was i gonna say
yeah so i guess diana ross was in the
supremes and then it became diana ross
and the supremes and then he was all
like well hey man i want to be david
ruffin
and and the temptations
and you know because men solved their
problem with violence i think the other
four was like well there's four of us
how about we beat the [ __ ] out of you
instead and it's still called the
temptations
and
and then eventually he left see if those
other two broads and the supremes just
slapped diana around a little bit they
would have just been called the supremes
that's my theory anyway
um
so
he ends up going solo and i downloaded
uh
one of his albums called who i am it's a
[ __ ] great album
and then that caused me
to see well what did these other guys do
that were in the temptations where did
they go
there was another guy there what the
[ __ ] was his name
eddie lundergaard jerry lundergaard no
that's the wrong one
where the [ __ ] is it artists
songs
keep on trucking
oh yeah eddie kendricks and i downloaded
this song eddie kendrick's uh keep on
trucking
which ended up if you listen to the
whole song
is the sample
for that that lights camera action
i'm sorry miss jackson whatever [ __ ]
song that is
um it's the breakdown towards the end
um i don't like that eddie kendricks as
much
like he sings in like that falsetto and
it gets annoying really fast
it's like it's nice if somebody else is
singing and then he comes in with the
high-pitched thing as a different sort
of color in there but if when it's just
him doing it the whole time it's just
like jesus christ
your voice is higher than the women
singing behind you
so
anyway i've been listening to a bunch of
that stuff and there's some killer
[ __ ] drummers on there
and on that david ruffin one there was
uh
just this really weird beat
that was being played by this drummer
because it still had like a motown feel
but it was also kind of like
that you know that hi-hat opening and
closing
that was done to death during the whole
disco era it was sort of moving towards
that because the album came out like
1976 right before the whole like
disco explosion
and you know i never realized
that night when they were the death to
disco and all that the amount of white
people that came down there that brought
albums down that were not disco
those people bringing stevie wonder
albums down there and stuff um
it's weird it all started off with that
guy making fun of the bee gees and all
of a sudden became like a hate rally
[Laughter]
human beings man
we're the [ __ ] worst we really are
the worst if we can [ __ ] come up with
a way
we will invent ways that's another thing
you know on this this social media [ __ ]
i just love the name calling
and i don't mean like yeah go [ __ ]
yourself you [ __ ] or whatever i
don't mean like just you know generic
stuff
like um
i like with covid it became like you're
either on this side or the other side so
the people that are vaccinated want to
get vaccinators i am the vaccinator
people who wants to get facts want
people to be vaccinated they came up
with like cove idiots
and spread necks and all of that [ __ ]
and it's just like what are we [ __ ]
five years old people like oh i love
that i'm gonna start saying that
it's like okay and then like what is
that gonna do
what is that gonna do is it gonna make
the person on the other side
like listen to what you have to say i
actually saw this nurse
i was trying to listen to it because i
woke up early because i [ __ ] took
nyquil last night first alcohol i've had
in a while
[ __ ] took one of those to their head
was just out
was [ __ ] man that's why i'm in a
[ __ ] up mood i ate like [ __ ] three
handfuls of [ __ ] molasses based
chocolate and then i took a shot at
nyquil and went to bed no wonder i got
no argument with my wife this morning
um
oh sure bill blame the ingredients not
the [ __ ] person um
maybe you're an [ __ ] that probably
so
anyway
i woke up at like five in the morning
and i saw
this instagram post of this nurse
talking about how [ __ ] exhausted she
is
from this never-ending wave of people
coming in who have like [ __ ] cove the
level of selfishness of these [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's there's there's literally something
out there
that will prevent you from either
getting it or at least make it to the
point you don't have to go to the
hospital and all of this [ __ ]
and she has to go in there
to work with these [ __ ] warrants i
don't think that they should let people
in anymore
oh you got that [ __ ] oh yeah no we we
told you what to do you didn't do it
sorry there's people with cancer
you know
heart disease but then they tell you
what to do not to get heart disease i
don't know it's a tough thing
it's a tough thing
but uh
my favorite thing is the person that
like
is trashing hollywood
and celebrity like somehow like
you know it's not doctors all around the
world are telling you to get the vaccine
it's hollywood's doing it right
and then they talk about you know
celebrities and their poor behavior i
know i've talked about this before but i
just cannot get past
uh they're gonna look at you know
celebrities being douches but they're
gonna ignore the person that slams a
gallon of milk or a two-liter bottle
onto the ground because they're asked to
wear a mask in a [ __ ] convenience
store and then my favorite thing they
just walk out like uh who's supposed to
clean that up i guess we clean up after
you after you have a [ __ ] temper
tantrum
i mean dude
i'm not trying to divide people here but
can we just look at that person because
even if you're somebody who doesn't want
to get vaccinated you don't do [ __ ] like
that correct okay cool so now can we
laugh at that person
like how much of a [ __ ] baby are you
well i mean i uh
i'm telling you right now the vigilante
fantasies i had about that i had
i just wanted to be i wish i was strong
enough i'm just a [ __ ] old man
to just grab that person and clean up
the milk with his clothes while he's
still wearing him and just dragging the
guy back and forth
[Music]
take him out ring him out in the
dumpster and bring him back and just dre
you know
um
but whatever it's all working out
because i feel like i can go back to
work and just stand at the back of the
stage
and uh i'll just you know
i guess i mean i can't say i'm 100 not
give a [ __ ] when you watch a nurse going
like i'm [ __ ] exhausted i can't
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] anymore
well then maybe you should get another
[ __ ] job i think i'm not tired
i've beaten kova three times thanks to
you
um all right that is the podcast
everybody uh
before we get out of here we actually
have a little bonus here uh me and paul
verzi
with uh bet mgm are picking nfl football
games
um and at this point we're both three
and five we've won three out of five
game out of eight games that we've
picked
that's pretty pathetic
we are both below 500 we are both on the
hot seat
um so
when you listen this week you got to be
thinking all right are they due to win
or do you win by doing the opposite of
what we do all right that's coming up
next
what's up everybody and welcome to the
anything better week three nfl preview
remember guys if you haven't signed up
yet we've got a special offer for our
listeners and you'll be able to make a
week three
free
that's it that's right week free free
free sign up for the new bet mgm account
use bonus code burr b u r r can't be
easier b u r
and you'll get fifty dollar free bet
just for signing up that's right you
don't even need to make a deposit to get
in on the action guys all right now we
gotta talk up picks paul
yes so we gotta talk about what happened
last week so me and bill seem to be
after week two we are both three and
five
uh bill went one and three this week i
went one and two which was basically
what we uh two and two
i went two and two you went one and
three and that's basically the opposite
of what we did week one we're both
sitting at three and five which is i
couldn't pick my ass at this point i
like where we are bill we're fine i
don't i i i like if our listeners bet
the exact opposite
paul if we're a manager of a baseball
team right now and we're winning we're
winning three out of every [ __ ] eight
games we're on the hot city paul look
we're on the hot seat right now
our wives get nervous that we're gonna
have to sell the house we're gonna
see what happens why week two is so
difficult is because nobody really knows
who anybody is after week one and then
everybody puts all this [ __ ] [ __ ] on
week one like oh that's who they are
like my dumb ass oh my god the [ __ ]
saints destroyed
you know
[ __ ] uh aaron rodgers and the packers
they're going into uh carolina they're
gonna kill him they don't even show up
paul
no so i want i want i want you to tell
me paul you tell me after two weeks you
tell me who the [ __ ] those saints are
no the saints are a nine and seven team
dude eight and eight
you know they're not the saints dude
jameis winston man i hate to be a dick
jameis winston's a decent quarterback
the saints aren't going to do [ __ ] dude
you got you know i think
he says the saints will not come
marching in this year no they're going
to be a decent team it'll be fun to
watch 500 maybe a little over 500
they're not going where are they going
where are they going you know it's the
bucks it's it's arizona
where they're going you know
um
yeah well listen dude
i was stupid with the jets the patriots
i should have never even [ __ ] touched
that game who bets on the jets paul what
what person and you live in new york so
you you you
you know who they are
i thought i've known who they are which
is hilarious i was hoping for uh for a
miracle here you're a giants fan because
of the jets
the jets are so bad the nfl gives you
another option if you live in new york
uh you think metlife charges the jets
more rent
i'm the least they probably give them a
break like a like a landlord with a
heart during a [ __ ] pandemic
all right man i'm sorry about those
first two weeks sorry we'll give you
week three off
that's hilarious for week four you gotta
start paying again all right
oh [ __ ] i watched that game dude like uh
i gotta tell you something though that
is one of the better jet teams i've seen
since uh rex ryan
was coaching them where they were they
got a great running back i thought their
defense was solid they looked good
everywhere but at the qb position and
that guy had a career bad day
um i don't think our defense was that
[ __ ] good but he's moved us up in the
rankings paul we're at top 10 defense
right now
after two weeks the new england patriots
i'll tell you what man mack jones
i think you guys got another quarterback
that's going to be good i really do i
think
jinx and paul no no that running back
put your mark sanchez [ __ ] hex on him
after two games no no no i didn't i
listen i haven't watched him enough to
even say that but i think harris too
that running back harris i listened to a
long interview with that guy 37 the guy
that [ __ ] took seven jets in the end
zone with him that guy's [ __ ] awesome
you guys have a good team man you guys
are yeah that was the mini uh that was
the mini marshawn lynch yeah that was a
[ __ ] run dude that was a run but here
we are at at week three and this is
where i need to get 500. this is where i
need this is where paulie's gonna put it
into fifth and [ __ ] pass cars on the
highway okay okay this is this is
now for this enough of this staying with
traffic all right um
uh
i think i think i
bill you went first last week i think i
go first this week go ahead
um i got to make sure that i get the
well you know what i'll give you the
first one i'll give you the first one as
i look i'm only taking this game because
i'm going to be there and that's what
i'm doing tooth and you've got to bet on
a game you got to have some juice on a
[ __ ] game but what are we doing we're
just sitting outside eating hot dogs
right
uh i'll tell you this me and the versey
clan will be there both my kids my wife
we're going to giants falcons and
and
it's eli manning retirement speech
bobblehead it's going to be eli day and
we just happen to by by chance get those
tickets
giants are favored by three i truly
believe the giants won twice last week
and still [ __ ] lost they got [ __ ] i
like how daniel jones looked
daniel jones actually looked pretty good
with some time saquon had a decent run
i'm taking my giants while i'm in the
building with my family on eli manning
day minus three against the falcons we
get our first win and the giants go one
and two after next week that's my first
pick and damn it i like that one oh i
like that one i like that one because
you haven't won yet
have the falcons won yet
i don't think so and they're you know
they they
they tried to
dude the falcons figure out ways to lose
and until they stop doing that you got
to keep your money away from them that's
just my opinion
all right paul i'm betting this game
because i'm also going to it i'm taking
the tampa bay buccaneers
with tom terrific who's working on a
release now that's as fast as dan marino
and his prime
crazy given one point
in los angeles
at the new
environmental disaster stadium
whatever the [ __ ] they call it down
there
who's that the chargers no the rams
there was no reason to build that
stadium paul there was nothing wrong
with the la memorial coliseum there was
nothing wrong with a little coat of
paint here or there
you know i mean you're either a sports
fan or you're not if they got to have
like a [ __ ] food cart sitting right
next to your fat ass in the aisles
you know did you see that giant dumbass
tv screen that they have i knew some
idiots were going to build one bigger
than what the cowboys built you never do
that you do these
you don't look for you don't look at
dallas for taste
no
it's bigger it's better you know morons
these stadiums look like spaceships i
will say though the one that the raiders
built in las vegas it it just looks like
a normal one but it's like shiny and
black it looks kind of cool but like
some of these are just like no that
one's super fancy too which is what the
funniest thing is is then you have the
humor of it is those animal raider fans
next to a [ __ ] sushi bar is hilarious
a guy dressed as darth vader getting a
[ __ ] spicy tuna rolls hilarious
he's gotta lift up the mask
he's got the teardrop tattoo because
he's killed somebody uh um
actually if i had to live in texas so i
think i would live dallas dallas or
houston if i lived in texas it would be
dallas 100
yeah
um
houston's not quite there
although it would be great to go to joel
osteen's shows every week and heckle
them hey i'll tell you where i wouldn't
live in texas
austin okay [ __ ] dump
[Laughter]
that i'll go there to hang out with joe
rogan but i would not go down there
i literally saw comedians on their phone
at moon tower going yeah i walked around
this is the most overrated [ __ ]
i mean austin is i i've been to a lot of
cities i'll tell you what top three
worst ever as far as downtown dude i
wouldn't go that far i just think that
there's a lot of transients in there
bringing it down i know a lot of great
people that do live there
and uh i love the texas longhorns the
downtown area is beautiful
uh but it's just you know i you know i'm
not hedging my bet on this one it stinks
i i'm too uh
i'm too old for austin
i like dallas dallas seems like he can
be an adult there you can put on a sport
coat and drive your pickup truck in that
town
uh all right man this is my second pick
all right
number two
hey here's the deal you gotta pick the
city and [ __ ] you gotta pick the team
and then [ __ ] on the city
i don't know man this is a tough one for
me dude this is
this is a tough one
all right the jacksonville jaguars are
are are haven't won a game they're
playing all right
they're at home
they haven't won a game
and they're getting seven
and urban meyer got asked in a press
conference were you out coached and boy
the look on his face and the way he felt
um
trevor lawrence threw that nice pass i
think he might be getting comfortable
i'm gonna take the j i'm gonna i can't
believe this dude because i love a
favorite i can't [ __ ] believe this
but
i'm gonna take the jags at home getting
seven oh my god jordan is starting to
pass the ball
i'm gonna jersey he's taking underdogs
i'm gonna lose man no i'm taking the
jacksonville jaguars plus seven at home
against the cardinals just want to see
how they respond or if they're going to
just go 0-3 i got to see it you know the
way you know the way when you're playing
poker and you know you're like i got to
see the cards i got to see it
so i'm going to take i got to tell you i
love
the arizona cardinals and um what's his
face
chandler jones who i always loved as a
patriots had five sacks the first
[ __ ] week didn't he didn't get a sack
last week i imagine they were keying in
on him but
um they got kylo murray i don't know
paul i don't know i i but i would love
to see arizona kill him
oh wait you know something though but
urban meyer he might be the next pete
carroll
you know where he was at some big flashy
school that was skirting the [ __ ]
rules
then he slithers into the nfl
that's doing well i shouldn't say
slither that's [ __ ] that's slanderous
um anyway
all right my next pick
uh speaking of pete carroll man i
[ __ ] watch these guys every week i
love this i don't know what happened
when i a few years ago
when there was a you mad bro and all of
that [ __ ] and beast mode i [ __ ]
hated the seattle seahawks now i love
them
i love them they're fun russell wilson's
my favorite [ __ ] quarterback in the
nfl i love watching the guy play
they're in minnesota
they're given to
none of that makes sense but i'm taking
him anyways i'm going seattle two
favorites paul i i can't even see the
angles anymore paul
i'm at the pool table i'm scratching on
every shot
you have taken me completely out of my
game this is a tricky week because going
on three the percentage of making
playoffs like this is the week that
teams are like we can't go all in three
that's why week three is tricky but i
like that pick i like that big gun to my
head that's a good pick
all right here we go
is somebody injured on seattle i really
should have looked that up why is it
only [ __ ]
because i saw what's his face last week
he looked like he got up hobbling
they're running back that was it delvin
cook
all right dude
that is oh you were so [ __ ] in that
you didn't hear what i just said
i can't believe i'm doing this
my favorite
my favorite my favorite team to watch in
the nfl this year is the baltimore
ravens okay
they're in detroit and they're laying
nine
and i'm gonna take the lions getting
nine at home you [ __ ] that's a
great bit i was gonna take that one you
son of a [ __ ]
okay so now where do i go where do i go
from here paul well you know what we got
going on here is we got a couple of uh
we got a couple of interesting ones here
yeah where you know i love a division
rivalry paul oh i know where he's going
i see what he's looking at and i always
think the games are gonna be close you
know what i thought i was going there
but then i realized it was in pittsburgh
you know [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
i'm gonna take joe burrow and the
bengals going into pittsburgh
yeah i think they're gonna
because it makes no sense right they
lost last week the steelers i lost money
on them those [ __ ]
um
big ben's a little banged up although i
think he plays better when he's banged
up [ __ ] i hate this week paul
i hate this week let me go hang on a
second hang on a second go ahead take
your time
ah
[Music]
the raiders
where's the raider game they're playing
somebody i know they're playing over
there with all those [ __ ]
lunatics eating their sushi now where's
the [ __ ] raider game
i got it on my list of picks here
they're not playing monday night no
they're playing the dolphins
minus four
and where are they
vegas
oh [ __ ] that the dolphins got smoked
smoked by buffalo last week
why is it only four points why do they
always have to scare me paul i figure
that would be seven points the vegas
raiders are two 2-0
i feel like a sucker right now they are
2-0 they look good dude
yeah and miami look like lackluster
against buffalo and tua got hurt but
he's kind of gonna play but he got
banged up bad
got carted off
jesus christ yeah look at you trying to
steer me into this bet you [ __ ]
oh no no no i'm just i'm just i know i
know how you work
i know how you [ __ ]
upstate new york people are
um
i'm also looking at the chargers getting
six and a half in kansas city
i don't know i can't bet on the charges
i don't believe in them you know what
okay all
right all right [ __ ] this i'm going joe
burrow in the bengals
joe birl
i love joe burrow man i love joe burl
and he smokes sticks when he wins
championships
gotta love that guy giant [ __ ] cigar
do i take the jets getting ten and a
half or do i take the tennessee titans
laying five and a half at home against
the colts you know what i took i took
one favorite and two dogs let's even it
out with two favorites and two dogs i'm
gonna take the tennessee titans laying
five and a half at home against the
indianapolis colts
uh derrick henry looks like a [ __ ] in
the tank of old derrick mike grebel's a
great coach that's a great pick dude i
love that and their home in nashville so
there you go two favorites two dogs
and there it is all right i got a i got
a favorite
given one what do i got i got i got
seattle you got seattle you got the
bengals and i got tampa
you got tampa
where is he going with number four where
is he going people
like a housewife trying to win on
[ __ ] the price is right look at that
monday night game dude i wanted no part
of that though oh you know what [ __ ]
this i think
uh
i can't see anything this year paul
it's too early dude well no i feel like
jameis winston is the exact kind of
quarterback that bill belichick
throughout his career
has feasted upon
okay
he's got a little bit of experience but
not with the saints even though he's
been there but he hasn't been under
center this is just we have a great
[ __ ] defense
god damn it
great defense uh
i know it's two it's week two we got a
great defense okay we've had two good
[ __ ] games
does that mean anything
um
he can't lay off the pat's andrew he
just he's like me with the where do i go
the raiders do i go the raiders
do i keep forgetting who the [ __ ]
they're playing the raiders playing the
[ __ ]
so-and-so's
the vegas that's why because it says las
vegas i go right by it the miami
dolphins
four [ __ ] why is it only four points
paul
why isn't it five and a half for six
i'm gonna tell you i'll tell you after
because i don't want you to think i'm
trying to
push you a certain way
no tell me give me some information i
think the raiders are going to be six
and oh seven and one i think they're the
raiders are [ __ ] no no i thought you
knew something about the game i [ __ ]
i'm gonna take the raiders god damn it
yeah you know it's about time that
animal [ __ ] fan base
you know paul just when you didn't think
the raider fan base
after being in los angeles and oak and
oakland could have more animals
in that [ __ ] end zone they then moved
to las vegas
they are like commercial fishing
mouth-breathing morons into that stadium
i think it's going to be loud i think
it's going to be hostile i think it's
going to be ignorant
and dude they're scoring all kinds of
points i think john gruden's got him
going in the right direction i think the
wheels are falling off in miami i'm
going raiders oh i love it uh andrew you
got all this right
nice dude i have a heart i have i have a
soft spot in my heart for the raiders
that's the first team i ever played for
and i was a defensive back number 27 on
the raiders pop boy that young football
[ __ ] it was it was i love the raiders i
also you know their fans are [ __ ] fun
i did a thing a long time ago where i
did some man in the street stuff up
there they they're [ __ ] hardcore you
have to be hardcore if you're a raiders
fan the way they've been playing for the
last i don't know other than that john
the first john how weird is it that john
gruden is back
20 years he's like gabe kaplan right
going back to his old [ __ ] high
school with the sweathogs trying to make
him winners again you have to watch his
youtube mic'd up there's 13 minutes of
him miked up throughout his whole career
there's nobody funnier there's nobody
funnier with refs there's nobody funnier
with players in practice he'll walk up
and start talking about the
[ __ ] that has nothing to do with the
games and then other game it's then
about the game the best
um andrew i got a future bet for you i
got a future bet for you dude i'll give
it to you after week two
i think matt stafford
the the new quarterback of the rams
finally has a [ __ ] team and that kid
is throwing darts all over the [ __ ]
field i'll take a [ __ ] future bet
he'll be mvp of the of the league
i'll take that bet
you're saying no or you like to bet no
i'll take it i'll i'll take that action
poll let's do it my way
let's do it now you got the ball send it
my way i'll take that [ __ ] action all
day long plus 1100 so that's uh that's
five dollars to make sixty if you were
to make that bet five will get you sixty
who's the top five uh mvp one ap mvp nfl
award
who's a top five for it can you be an
mvp if you're not a quarterback it
usually is a quarterback right
no
no some running backs can get it
who larry zazonka who's the last guy i
want to [ __ ]
emily i think ladain and thomason want
it i think there's been a problem thomas
and jesus christ that guy's in like a
[ __ ] old folks home at this point
he's younger than me
i'm kidding
that guy is yeah he's probably like 43.
but his body
as far as far as what types of bets
people are making the highest ticket for
nfl mvp uh kyler murray is 15 of all
wages for nfl mvp this season second
josh allen third matt stafford
oh i like the kyler murray josh allen
debate which i believe stephen a smith
was having with somebody and it was so
funny neither one would say i like a
white quarterback and the other guy
wouldn't say i like a black quarterback
but they were saying everything but that
it was hilarious
i like tyler murray but let's be honest
josh allen you would take to be your
franchise quarterback any [ __ ] day of
the week
as far as line movement goes yeah but i
would say
this is my thing though
kyler murray as long as he doesn't get
[ __ ] hurt
i mean that guy is unbelievable he is
but he runs around he's like a gnat dude
and if he doesn't get hurt yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying but but you're
not betting overall career you're
betting early on we're betting this guy
in my experience watching guys that run
around eventually
you get caught and you do and then they
[ __ ] you up and if you haven't developed
as a pocket passer and they take away
some of your speed it can get ugly
you can start looking like me back there
paul really quickly
who ran an 8 second 40 in the prime of
his life
um it couldn't have been eight seconds i
think it was a seven something dude it
would definitely would have been eight
dude you would have been have to hold in
your book bag if it was eight
ah
all right guys well this is i was
well you don't understand how wide i am
i have those giant white guy calves
like my calves are as big as my thighs
[Music]
i got a lot of drag when i'm coming down
the way i think i was running in
shelters too
i'm a redhead i was out in the sun i
mean i just had everything working
against me oh dude irish kids in high
school loved shell toes all my irish
friends in high school they all rocked
the shelter
the clatter rings yeah you guys are
listening to [ __ ] house of pain and
[ __ ]
well that was after that was
yeah house of pain that was big that was
in the 90s but i was already too old to
be at that party paul well there you
guys go i don't know who you're rooting
for if you're team burr your team versi
we're both three and five those are our
picks for week three paul you they
should be team them
and at this point i mean paul we got to
be honest here
you know
we got to do our exit interviews here
you know we didn't get it done last week
no we didn't no and just just going two
and two is not something that i want to
hang my hat on you know there's been a
big tradition out here
of me beating paul verzi
year after year oh two years relax i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what man two
years two years baker mayfield [ __ ] me
dude they should have won that game they
needed one more field goal well you
[ __ ] yourself the second you walked up
to the table to make your bet who are
you kidding
you're gonna blame it on that guy uh
baker mayfield won last week i know but
they speaker mayfield has put the
cleveland browns
in the driver's seat i had him brought
down to the playhouse how did he [ __ ]
you paul would he go into your house and
knock a picture off the wall no he
should have put it another field goal
to cover he didn't cover he won by ten i
needed him to win by twelve and a half
but he's not a field goal kicker the man
throws and runs for touchdowns that's
what he does you know what i deserve two
and two with the jets pick i deserve two
and two
i mean that's pretty generous
yeah it's pretty generous to think that
you only deserve two and two if you're
gonna go right you're gonna go around
picking the jets and it's a rookie
quarterback on the jets and it's a
division rival against the patriots and
the i mean it's just it's just and you
know what i'm seeing right now is i'm
seeing the growth of you as a gambler
you know at first i thought this guy's
all over the map
he's he he's he's he's rudderless he
doesn't know what he's doing he's just
and i was like wait a minute
rudder paul is taking chances
because he's trying to the same way
you've grown as a comedian
bill i lost trying to grow bill i lost
the jimmy the greek title twice in a row
i got to change this franchise all right
i you [ __ ] yourself i don't want to
talk [ __ ] but you have lost
every season that we've done this
and i've won every season yeah we've
done it twice
but you've lost i know but you're making
the listeners think we've done this for
11 years we've done it twice paul
we've done this over the course of 32
weeks
and you can
and you could not pull the car
uh out of the side part what i'm doing
right now is getting people rooting for
you
paulie's the underdog this year and he's
taken underdogs i love it paul i love
seeing the growth of you as a degenerate
gambler hey you know what andrew you
should ask if bet mgm could come up with
odds on who's gonna win me or bill since
he's the two-time champion vegas says
bill's got this vegas says bill's got
this probably i would say 15 more chance
to me
according to vegas
[Laughter]
that'd be great if we made a bet like
that
did you freeze bill
guys thanks so much this has been the uh
week three nfl preview of the anything
better podcast and remember guys if you
haven't signed up yet we've got special
offer just for our listeners
okay you'll be able to make uh week
three bets for free sign up for a new
bet mgm account and use a bonus code
burr that's b-u-r-r you'll get a 50 free
bet for uh just for signing up that's
right you don't even need to make a
deposit to get in on the action
if you haven't signed up for bet mgm yet
use a bonus code burr and you'll get a
50 free bet to use for this week's games
hey guys visit bet mgm.com for terms of
conditions 21 years of age or older to
wager arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan new jersey
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia or wyoming only excludes
michigan disassociated persons please
gamble responsibly guys gambling problem
call 1-800 next step arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia 1-800-270-7117
for confidential help michigan 1-800
gambler new jersey pennsylvania west
virginia 1-800 bets off iowa call or
text the tennessee red line 800-889-9789
tennessee or call 1-800-9
with it in indiana guys there you go
that responsible all right everybody
that's the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
um please enjoy the little interlude
music and after this after that there'll
be a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast where
we play an episode that was uh i don't
know from a year or two ago and uh
hopefully gives you some extra laughs
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend you [ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
[ __ ] monday
uh september 23rd
2013. what's going on what's going on
dude what's up see the [ __ ] pats you
know you didn't think they were that
good you're [ __ ] 3-0 now
now what they didn't think so didn't
think so
um
more on that later
i am uh back in the continental united
states
i just did uh two wonderful shows
up in uh toronto ontario it's first time
i've been up to uh canada
in a while had a great time
and uh right before that i was in
pittsburgh had a lovely time there
thanks all the guys at uh dve
randy bauman
uh bill crawford opening it up killing
killing killing at the heinz hall and
then before that i was down there at uh
in west virginia
another beautiful state
that everybody shits all over
i'm telling you i'm gonna retire in one
of those [ __ ] states that is my game
plan
the game plan is i'm gonna somehow get
these [ __ ] banker [ __ ] off of me
gonna pay off this goddamn house
and then
you know when i'm too [ __ ] old
you know
my hair's all
white or yellow whatever happens to
[ __ ] red hair and on top i got those
freckled
old age spots on my bald head i'm just
going to be ah [ __ ] ollie
[Laughter]
and i'm going to sell this place
and i will move to like
i don't know west virginia
uh i moved to iowa but like what the
[ __ ]
you know
now that was good bill that was great i
i really understand the topography now
of iowa with that vivid description
thank you i'm over here in wales england
and now i understand exactly
what iowa looks like i'm sorry i maybe
what the the dakotas
something along those lines
um
i'm just gonna move to the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere
and by then maybe i'll have a pilot's
license
and i can go out like john denver
and i just think that that would be a uh
that'd be a lovely life
it would be a lovely life
um
no i've actually you know just been
driving around seeing all the uh
different parts of the country here man
i i'm getting back into driving to stuff
in fact by the way last week
i got a brutal email from somebody
telling me what a piece of [ __ ] i am and
all this type of stuff because i had to
cancel
my gig in el paso and it's like i didn't
cancel the [ __ ] thing it rained
and it's not my fault that you guys
don't have a sewer
system or whatever the [ __ ] it is out
there in el paso and i told you that i
would rescue i [ __ ] flew out there
i was sitting there i had my show shirt
all ironed i was ready to go but as
promised i said we will reschedule the
el paso date as soon as possible and i
am a man of my [ __ ] word the el paso
date the new date
is uh
october 2nd
all right
and instead of dude i call it versi
uh i'm actually bringing rose bowl
legend tailgate legend
mr joe bartnick everybody okay
a man who honed his skills
in the san francisco san francisco scene
man
and uh that's that's a wednesday
that's a great run wednesday is uh
is el paso
thursday the third
is uh san jose friday the fourth is
seattle and then the fifth of october is
uh i'm back down in phoenix
and uh so anyways so if you if you
bought tickets already for el paso those
things are totally honored if you can't
make october 2nd
your your money will be refunded
any more than that
i i there's nothing else i can i can't
control the [ __ ] weather
so um
anyways
i've been getting uh i've been slammed
lately
there were some people in seattle did
not take kindly to my [ __ ]
my song that i sang next week i got
called like a [ __ ] like 58 times on
twitter this week
[Laughter]
um
yeah people did not appreciate that song
although they did not refute it
no one ever said they didn't
go out of their way to architecturally
in a way architecturally design how else
would you do it bill
huh how else would you do it
i'm trying to think of another big word
but i don't have what
i don't i was gonna say geometrically
but you probably need geometry any
geometry for that [ __ ] that's not a good
one uh
peanut butter and jelly yeah way i don't
[ __ ] know anyways you know what i
love about in a couple i guess a couple
people just wrote some of the blurb that
i wrote to piss off all these seahawk
fans
um
and uh they left out the whole part
where i said all the complimentary stuff
and how they got a great team and how
when i watched the patriots play and
then i see you know seattle or frisco or
colts or whatever watch those games how
it just looks like football on a whole
other level and now seattle has a great
chance at winning the super bowl and now
i don't blame [ __ ] pete carroll for
what the [ __ ] he did at usc because
everybody does it yet all of that [ __ ]
gets left out
only thing that they had in there was we
was me going we
are the loudest my friends
someday people of seattle fans of the
seattle seahawks as mad as you are that
you have to use those homophobic slurs
in your advanced city man
um
you'll you'll you'll understand it one
of these days one of these days when you
actually have something shiny in your
cupboard
until now you're just screaming
that's all you're doing and then you
know
that's another reason why you guys are
so loud
because of how empty your trophy case is
it causes an echo
[Laughter]
you guys came in the league in 1977
along with the tampa bay buccaneers and
even those sad [ __ ] figured out a
[ __ ] way to win one by now all right
so even if you finally win one this year
i got two words for you it's about
[ __ ] time all right and if you can't
do the math on that i can't help you
i'm just [ __ ] around
all right you [ __ ] birds relax
i'll be up there on the fourth do
whatever the [ __ ] you want boom me i
don't give a [ __ ]
they give me the check already
all right
that's actually not true but i'm gonna
act like it is so anyways plowing ahead
here
um yes i was up in toronto one of the
great things about going up to uh to uh
canada
aside from the fact that hockey is the
first
story you know when it comes to sports
that's the big thing that's going on i
watched like hockey night in canada i
came home and i watched the replay
they're showing pre-season hockey up
there
like it's [ __ ] march
okay and they're trying to figure out
who's gonna make the playoffs playoffs
and uh somebody actually uh i watched a
little bit of the toronto buffalo game
some of the uh
replay no no i watched edmonton
vancouver
that's what i was watching somebody just
sent me a link
to this great brawl
um i'll i'll give you guys the video of
it and and all you guys who don't like
hockey just spare me you're stupid
great sport why do they let them fight
this is a sport
just i gotta be honest with you guys
that's music to my ears i like that
people don't understand hockey that you
can't see the puck for whatever [ __ ]
reason i love it i love it keep keep
piling on
and watching football and go down to
your sports bar with your man tits and
your [ __ ] football jersey i'm all
about it
by all means i'll sit over in the quiet
part of the bar watching a hockey game
without you and your [ __ ] uh cheetos
breath
invading my shoulder area near my nose
know your shoulders need your nose right
i was thinking looking over my shoulder
out with it i don't need to explain my
body parts to you people all right
um
so anyways
whatever two guys on the one guy
on toronto one guy at buffalo they get
into a fight and the guy in buffalo his
helmet comes off
and uh he [ __ ] ended up whacking his
head on the ice and i guess buffalo took
an exception to that
so this [ __ ] big goof
scott
this big goof that could beat the living
[ __ ] out of me but i'm safe here in the
podcast so i'll call him a goof knowing
nothing about him i'm sure he's a
wonderful well-spoken human being
but he looked like a big goof because
he's standing next to phil kessel phil
kessel comes up to like i don't know
maybe his hockey pants his little short
shorts his little satin booty shorts
that he's wearing
and uh he decides to take it out on him
he takes a swing at little phil kessel
little phil never hurt anybody just
trying to score a goal and some assists
doesn't even go in the corners
he's not hurting anybody
and i don't i did phil kessel lost his
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i have a whole newfound respect for that
guy
this big dude punched him so one of the
other [ __ ] maple leaf guys
immediately grabbed scott and phil
kessel takes a two-hander not once but
twice
to the back of scott's leg now i know a
lot of you guys go well what the [ __ ]
he's tied up with somebody else that's a
cheap shot [ __ ] you
all right
when you're two feet taller than a guy
when you have to punch down at the top
of somebody's head at that point you
might want to pick a different dance
partner right but he didn't so he
[ __ ] whacks him twice and then
squares off with another guy in the
sabers
and actually wins the fight bloodies the
guy up they stop
and then kessel is he's going to skate
off the ice
that big dude scott is still tied up
with somebody went over and he [ __ ]
spared him
trying to take out the guy's spleen i
was like good for him
there you go that's good phil you don't
take no [ __ ] off nobody he went all
spider on
why don't you go [ __ ] yourself tommy
it was great it was great to see and um
i think the leafs hopefully i think
they're going to be good this year
i like the leafs i've always liked them
um
and speaking of that oh yeah we're going
to talk hockey here in september
somebody sent me an an article
uh that said um
you know you know you always got to have
some sort of controversial title
just to get people to read it says
montreal canadians the most overrated
franchise in nhl history and they
basically touched on some [ __ ] that i
had brought up
broughton that i had brought up
um
you know through of course not reading
just overhearing [ __ ] that saying that
you know the canadians dominated a
six-team league and that they had first
pick at all french-born canadian players
yada yada all of that this is a really
cool article because
it actually explains that more
and it makes me understand but makes me
understand
montreal and toronto better
um
so this is the point the guys making i
don't i don't agree with all of this
stuff but it says the original six teams
uh carries an aura with them uh the
montreal canada you know the six teams
all did battle each other um so
basically you had a
16.67 percent chance of winning so of
course everybody's going to argue well
so did the bruins so did the blackhawks
sort of the red wings so did everybody
else but here
here's the thing that's really
interesting about this unless you're not
into uh hockey then i i i don't know
what to tell you
is um
ah christ i don't even have it here
where the [ __ ] is it
basically this is how it worked worked
you couldn't like
sign anybody back in the day so the
canadians did not have first chance at
all french-born canadian players what
they had back there was something i
guess called the sea form
which if you went out you scouted people
they had to sign if they signed it that
was an iou that they were going to go
and play for you
so montreal was smart enough to go all
over canada
and try and sign these people like right
before they turned 18 or right as they
turned 18. but the big thing was
was you had first chance
at all players within basically a 50
mile radius
of your city this is really interesting
i never knew this
you had first chance at that
so
um
basically why that kind of tipped the
scales
was montreal and toronto
had first chance
at everybody and basically you know
quebec in ontario
where everybody's hockey crazy and comes
out of the womb skating and then you
look at like the bruins and we had first
chance
at trying to find a rocket richard in
like new hampshire
or the as they say here the rangers
trying to find the next best goalie in
newark new or hoboken new jersey
and it's really interesting because what
what he fails to bring up in this
article was that montreal didn't
dominate
a 16 league
um both montreal and toronto up until
1967 the year of expansion at that point
montreal had 14 cups
and uh
and and the the the maple leafs had 13.
so the two of them just by being up in
canada and being around all of that
talent and the fact that you only got a
16 [ __ ] league they will they were
able to go on a run
but um
you know i wonder if that helped detroit
too because detroit that 50-mile radius
would actually get them into uh
ontario a little bit
where people gave a [ __ ] and loved
hockey but it was a really interesting
article and i'm not here to [ __ ] on the
canadians god knows i do that enough but
that really clarified
um misinformation that i was putting out
there that that i mean i was looking at
like everything east of montreal they
owned you had to go play for the
canadians and i was like what the [ __ ]
that be like if you had a whole all of
new england
or whatever to draft for a particular
sport or something like that so my
apologies you won't hear this often too
the montreal canadiens franchise i was
wrong about that and now i now
understand why
montreal and toronto were kind of going
tit-for-tat with that 50-mile radius
thing was really interesting but at the
end of the day though that thing that
montreal was going around trying to find
all of this talent they did do the work
so you kind of got to give it up from on
uh on that level so there you go
look at that apologizing to the
canadians but i'll have a link to that
if you want to read it if you're a
sports nerd like me
um
it's a great article all the way through
i wouldn't say that montreal is
overrated but i i was
disappointed that the uh that the writer
of the article did not bring up the
toronto maple leafs and why they were
able to kind of go
you know strive for stride there with
the canadians up till 67. it was
basically in the 70s
i think right that's when the canadians
they won six
they also want they won in 68 and 69
i can't remember no
yeah i think they won 68 69 then bruins
won 70 then montreal 71 bruins 72
then montreal flyers flyers and then
montreal for the rest of the decade
that's how i went all right
jesus christ is there one woman left
listening to this podcast
and with that let's do some advertising
great timing bill great timing i get the
[ __ ] calendar out of the way here um
either way
hockey's coming back i'm really uh
excited about it oh you know when i was
in pittsburgh
um what the [ __ ] was i just gonna tell
you i i was hanging out with uh uh randy
from dve
and uh bill crawford
and you know they know paul uh
steigerwald i hope i'm saying his name
right steigerwald i always [ __ ] up the
pronunciations of anybody's last name if
it has more than two syllables but it
was just so insane they brought him
along
and uh
we kind of you know talked right after
after the show and
i've watched so much santa rice
just to hear his voice was insane
i just kept saying that to him going
like dude like
this it would be hilarious he would
start talking to me just talking about
regular stuff paul wood and i i had
everything i did could do to not start
looking around for the hockey game on tv
because i felt like i was listening to
like oh oh [ __ ] there's a hockey game on
i've just i basically i've watched a ton
of penguins games is what i'm trying to
say so uh that was a big thrill getting
to hang out with him but um anyway so
let's get to the uh
let's get to the goddamn uh
where is it here let's get to the
advertising for this week all right
everybody
dollar shave club dollar shave club
everyone there are so many things in
this world that irritate me having to go
to canada to smoke a cuban cigar
you know
that really irritates me is that the
only thing that irritates me this oh
this [ __ ] letter somebody wrote me
that i'll read later that also irritates
whatever you know there's a lot of
things that irritate me um
when so many things can irritate you why
add razors to this list
it's time to stop milking your razor
blades everybody i know with brand name
razors you're used to paying outrageous
prices and exhausting those razors until
they start to look like a rusty soda can
it's time to move on dollar shave club
delivers amazing quality blades to your
door for just a few bucks a month month
never think about it again they send a
pack every month so you can change your
blades every week i love these guys and
your face will love them too yeah i
don't know why nobody ever came up with
this before these guys i'm telling you
and their commercials are hilarious for
the one wipe charlies i'm going to put
up a link for that it's hilarious now
they have these offensive linemen are
going to be the spokesman for the one
wipe charlies which is
so it's so brilliant
everything that this this company is
doing
uh from what they're coming up with to
to how they're marketing it is it's
awesome it's entertaining
you need it it fills a void
god bless them all right back to the
copy uh they've got a new product called
one wipe charlie's it's a butt wipe for
men and it's classy you can put a top
hat on and use this and no one's gonna
question you check out the video for
that and sign up for your razors today
uh go to
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com
or go to billboard.com and click the
dollar shave club banana
all right hulu plus everyone
you probably tried hulu.com now with
hulu plus you can watch your favorite
shows anytime anywhere hulu plus lets
you watch thousands of hit tv shows and
a selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet and it all streams
in hd for the best best viewing
experience
uh with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite current tv shows like saturday
night live community family
family guy sorry uh breaking bad
you know uh the walking dead
the shows that i like where people get
killed
you can also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the
awesomes
starring snl seth meyers and moon boy
starring chris
chris o'dowd from bridesmaids look at
hulu plus with the original programming
hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films for only 790 month
7.99 a month you can stream as many
shows and movies as you want whenever
you want right now you can try hulu plus
for free for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com bill that's a special offer
for my listeners
all right make sure you use huluplus.com
so you get the extended free trial and
they will know that we sent you go to
huluplus.com bill now or click on the
hulu plus banner on the podcast page at
billbert.com all right continuing on
so this past week everybody
um
i actually rented a motorcycle
and lived to tell about it
um
i rented during a weekday
right and i uh i just went to a party
where i knew there was going to be no
cars or anything like that there was all
these twists and turns and that type of
thing and it was you know it's just like
it was fun man
it was a lot of fun scraped the pegs a
couple of times scared the [ __ ] out of
me i didn't realize that they give
you know so you won't fall down that was
definitely sent a jolt
through my head
but um
it was awesome man
i gotta tell you i really uh i really
enjoyed it i don't know it's like i said
i still don't think i'm gonna buy a
motorcycle or anything like that i just
wanted to remember
what i'd learned in in the in the class
so i ride with a buddy of mine who's
been riding forever and everything went
great the entire [ __ ] time
i said i did a great job for the amount
of time that i've been riding you know i
drove stick shifts my whole life so it's
the same concept the hardest thing is
you have to switch it
you know with rather than shifting
with your hand you know you're doing it
with your foot and rather moving the
clutch with your foot you do it with
your hand it's all that type of [ __ ] but
that motorcycle safety class that i took
i highly highly highly recommend taking
one of those
because um
they really they help you with turns and
i mean like like the [ __ ] you have to do
on a motorcycle when you go into a turn
it's not like a car
you know you don't have to worry about a
car tipping over
and you being launched out of it like
what you have to do in a car you'd have
to be basically going i would think over
35 miles an hour
40 miles an hour and then just cut the
wheel as hard as you could
to the point you were skidding sideways
even just to go on its side but even
then you're strapped in you got metal
all around you and airbags
um
so anyways we rode
i i made him go down and pick up the
bike i did it as safely as i could
possibly do it and i had the time of my
[ __ ] life so
and i got the confidence that i actually
rode the bike back to my house
um before i went to bring it back and i
live i live on a uh
i live on a hill that's on a turn
so
i came down and i was just like oh wait
well how the [ __ ] do i do this and i
went down and i brought it up and i'm
thinking like what do i do with the
kickstand and then i kind of had it at
the wrong angle and i swear to god i
tipped the bike over at zero miles an
hour
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
dude i was riding for three hours
around turns a whole [ __ ] thing all
the way up to fourth gear downshifting
looking through the turns the whole
[ __ ] thing did everything right and
then at zero miles an hour
i just was at the wrong angle where if i
put the kickstand down it was still
going to tip over and then i tried to
overcompensate and the thing just tipped
to the point of no return
and you don't really feel the weight of
the bike until it gets to that tipping
point i mean i didn't slam it down i
just basically dropped it down it was so
[ __ ]
embarrassing
and i bent the uh
i bent the uh
the front brake and i put some scratches
on the [ __ ] thing so
it ended up being an expensive day
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was so embarrassed it was a harley too
so i brought it back down to the place
and they're all you know they're like
nah nah that happens it happens or
whatever but i just you know i could not
if i should have just gone down their
little skirt
with what's left of my hair and pigtails
and be like oh my god all i tried to do
is put the kickstand down
i was really
it's been a while since i've been that
[ __ ]
embarrassed like i was uh
i felt shame
but other than that it was a great time
i was billy badass for about uh
i don't know for a couple hours and then
uh i don't know
whatever the biggest [ __ ] word you can
come up with that begins with b
huh billy blueberries i don't [ __ ]
know anyways why blueberries are bad not
if you stick them in a pie
i have the urge to make a pumpkin pie
this week
i want to practice before the holidays
um and i want to smoke a [ __ ] turkey
this year
i'm throwing [ __ ] down
you know that's one of the things when
the holidays come around you got to have
something that you make
you know you got to have your staple and
if you don't you got to have some sort
of hooch that you get from somewhere in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere that you
got to have something special you just
can't be another [ __ ] that puts on some
ugly sweater and just shows up and
stands there eating everybody else's
[ __ ] drinking all their [ __ ] booze
you know
you got to bring something i think you
know what they should you should do you
should have like basically
you should have a pre-thanksgiving party
in the beginning of october like a
pre-season game
and then you invite like 30 people over
knowing only 22 are gonna make
the [ __ ] roster on thanksgiving
but don't tell anybody
no that's not fair people try out for a
team they know they're trying out for a
team do that there you go then you
[ __ ] wear one of those bill belichick
cut off hoodies and you see what people
show up with
just a suggestion
no big deal um all right let's continue
with the sports um
people have been firing off letters to
me lately
and uh i never send letters to people i
never do
i never like i'll read something and
somebody annoys me
and i guess the reason why i don't do it
is because i have the outlet of the
podcast
or doing stand-up
so i never really feel the need like you
know i gotta
i don't know send this person like a
[ __ ] letter or something but i
actually sent a letter
an email
and i'm not gonna name the name because
i don't i don't want you guys to like
i know most of you won't but some of you
will find out who it is and then go you
stupid [ __ ] aged and you know
those stupid
you know write something racist that or
whatever i just don't want to be a part
of that but basically
this person was writing an article
about this female goaltender
uh brianna scurry i hope i said her last
name right
and um
you know it's really just
awful story you know like she was top of
her game playing for the u.s ladies
soccer team in the late 90s
and she went down to get to to stop a
routine uh you know routine save one of
those ones i think from the way it was
described was like kind of rolling fast
along the ground she dove down to get it
scooped it up and had it
and uh
someone on the other team went to
basically try to kick it out of her hand
real quick and then try to put it in the
goal but as they were running over to do
that
the other player's knee
struck this woman brianna right on the
side of her head
and uh
you know so she kind of gave herself a
standing account basically and stood up
and continued on like all athletes do
she pushed through the pain
so unfortunately after a few minutes the
back of her own players jerseys when she
was looking at the numbers and the names
started getting blurry started getting
fuzzy then she started seeing more than
one soccer ball out there and the team
could tell that she was struggling in it
and at the half they took her out of the
game sound like a familiar story
she had a brutal concussion and ended
her career
and now you know she has to stay in like
you know a dark apartment
and um
i don't know if she gets the bed spins
or gets nauseous but the usual type of
stuff so i'm reading this thing i was
like oh god another concussion story
this is i didn't
you know
i haven't heard a lot of soccer players
having this happen to them you know male
or female
um so it was really an interesting
article and then all of a sudden out of
nowhere
this person writes you know it's one of
the myths
of the mainstream sports media that
concussions belong only to men
most of them football players like
i i don't even i can't even wrap my head
around that statement
it's like
let me just let me just continue reading
this in fact studies show that women and
girls are more likely than men and boys
to suffer concussions in sports they
both play such as soccer basketball
and baseball slash softball
and in those cases they are also more
likely to suffer in private
a far cry from the attention
nfl players command
can you [ __ ] believe that
that was one of the most uninformed
paragraphs i think i've ever read on
like after i read that i was like i
don't think this paper usa today i don't
think that they have a sports editor
i don't even know where to begin with
that first of all to make concussions
like a gender issue
like i'm not the smartest guy but don't
we both just have brains
that sit in fluid
in your head
a blow to the head is a blow to the head
so i don't know what she's trying to
claim
and i my one of my favorite statements
of all time study show
no footnote to the study studies show
researchers have said
um
oh my god so i actually i i
i'm not going to bore you
maybe i will you want me to read the
letter that i sent her
i so i wrote no disrespect because i
wanted her to read
you know get something to
call her attention i basically said to
suggest that female athletes are more
likely to suffer in private a far cry
from the attention nfl players command
when it comes to suffering concussions
is astoundingly uninformed the attention
that nfl players command i kept putting
that in quote she made him sound like
they were divas
the attention nfl players command has
everything to do with generations of
former nfl players suffering in private
after their careers were over in the
last five years alone
three nfl players
have committed suicide by single gunshot
to the chest in order to preserve their
brains so scientists can figure out more
about the aftermath of playing
professional football the attention
players command today was a result of
over two decades of fighting tooth and
nail with nfl owners in the end the only
reason the owners gave in was the
irrefutable evidence gained through
examination of brains donated by dead
nfl players that suffered in private
and then i brought up the class action
suit blah blah blah
um
brian scurry was taken out of that
brian brianna scurry sorry was taken out
of the second half of that soccer game
because of all the suffering and private
that nfl players have endured because of
the knowledge gained by all of those
concussed football players that were
told to shake it off and get back in the
game this is a major issue in sport to
see it glossed over and actually turned
into some gender issue is incredibly
irresponsible i'm not saying you're a
bad person but to take such a serious
subject and not make it inclusive of all
human beings and then suggest that one
side has it worse than the other cited
more like fodder for the newlywed game
rather than a serious metal medical
discussion see that i can be eloquent
i don't have to trash people
well i can trash them but i don't have
to write uh all the curse words
you see that i had a very tuxedo kind of
vibe there didn't i
unlike this person who wrote to me oh
what a segue
uh ginger scumbag
bill
i've been a fan of yours for 15 years
okay so you guys got that
this guy
has been a fan of mine for 15 years
so for 15 years this guy has been
following me enjoying things that i'm
doing
all right
this guy's locked in for 15 years
the people that work hard every day and
spend their hard-earned cash that's kind
of redundant sir if you work hard then
you have hard-earned cash
all right you got an easy job you know
then you'd be spending your [ __ ]
titty money right
bill just read the [ __ ] email all
right just having fun
bill i've been a fan of this for 15
years the people that work hard every
day and spend their hard-earned cash to
see you have been really disappointed
this is one of the classic things when
people complain rather than just
complaining for themselves
they act like they're standing in front
of like a zillion people and they go
relax
attention everyone
i will send the email it will convey all
of your feelings
get on with your day relax
i will handle it
so evidently he has like you know
all of these people are disappointed in
me he said the people that follow you
and made you who you are
they made me people i didn't work hard
on stand-up i was just standing there
and they all said hey you
we have decided to make you and who you
are so said it be said so said it be
done
he said you have made dates all around
the country and then canceled them when
hollywood calls you to do a part that's
exactly what happened i picked up the
phone i said hello they said this is
hollywood here we're calling you to do a
part see
uh the people that go to your shows and
made you
that made you
aren't making a tenth of the money that
you make but they pay to see you hey
ginger boy
[Music]
without these fans
your illiterate ass would be working at
mcdonald's at best now i take offense to
that sir
okay without my fan base i would not be
working at mcdonald's you son of a [ __ ]
i would be unloading trucks in a
warehouse
get it straight
he goes you're a scumbag
b-a-g-e
you're a scum beige and i hope every fan
realizes what you are and stops going to
your shows
i will never listen to your shows or
podcasts again and will tell everyone to
do the same you are the typical sellout
to hollywood
[ __ ] disappointment
i know you won't have the balls to read
this on your podcast instead you will
read a letter from a 20 year old guy
confused about his girlfriend's
sexuality
this is the best part here you're a real
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you in everything you do
that's one of the greatest endings
one of the greatest settings to any
email i ever got you're a real [ __ ]
you're the real deal
if you if you tip over your [ __ ] you see
the stamp of approval
from the [ __ ] factory and then it's just
not [ __ ] you it's
[ __ ] you with everything you do
even when i go to the grocery store yeah
that too
[ __ ] you when you're picking out apples
um
jesus christ sir
you made me
did i have anything to do did i do
anything did i work did i not [ __ ] go
on stage and eat my balls learning how
to do this i guess you did all right
listen
i just want to thank you for making me
uh without your hard work of uh going
through i mean i can't imagine how many
i i mean how many people live in this
country i just can't imagine when you're
just going through the mug book trying
to figure out who you've decided will
become
a professional comedian that just and
the fact that you also have a day job
during the time
where i guess you're grossly underpaid i
mean that's just incredible to me
um sir what the [ __ ] do you want from me
let me ask you this
okay
if hollywood called you and asked you to
be in a movie
you're going to say no
all right and
like you told your mom hey listen ma
don't worry i'll come over and i'll
clean up your yard this saturday
all right
and then all of a sudden hollywood comes
to call and says hey do you want to
pretend you're a lot tougher than you
are and get into a gunfight and get shot
by i don't know whoever your favorite
actor is
you're going to say no
i have to go uh i gotta stick with
you've never broken a [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] that even like a playoff game
comes along you've never [ __ ] had to
change your schedule sir
i had to cancel some dates
i didn't cancel them i rescheduled them
the [ __ ] do you want from me
you want me to stay in the strip malls
for my entire career
telling jokes i did that i'm trying to
[ __ ] you know
and all all these movies do is make more
people know who i am so more people come
out to my shows so i can keep writing
more hours and having a good time
all right
i don't even know why i'm talking to you
you said you're never going to listen to
my [ __ ] again
right are you a man of your word after
you're saying i'm not a man of my word
if you're actually listening to this
then you're a [ __ ] hypocrite
all right what's the matter
huh
jesus
christ you [ __ ] pissed on your
sweatpants this week i don't know what
the [ __ ] that was all about you didn't
even say what what it was
you made dates all around the country
and then canceled them what the [ __ ] are
you talking about i had one tour i had
to move around and i [ __ ] did the
first two dates
then i've made up uh one two
three since then and added another one
that wasn't even on that original tour
so go [ __ ] yourself
all right all the tickets are honored
and if you can't make that date you get
it refunded
jesus christ you know that that tour
that i was gonna do i was just gonna
land in boise
you know
jump on a bus
and knock them all out in 10 days now
because that whole thing blew up now i
got to get on you know
it's like an extra 10 airplane ride you
don't hear me bitching
do you
you [ __ ] kind of you're a real [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you in everything you do that
was worth it
that was worth them getting mad that's
[ __ ] tremendous sir you know what as
much as you you disappointed me you're a
real disappointment you [ __ ] jerk off
you've liked me for 15 years one
canceled [ __ ] gig and now you now
you're saying [ __ ] me and everything i
do i make that pumpkin pie this week
you're saying [ __ ] the pie too
that's a part of it you're saying [ __ ]
america if you're saying [ __ ] punk
pumpkin pie
but i gotta i am a real [ __ ] you know i
can't argue that
[Laughter]
uh
you know something can somebody please
put that on a t-shirt
you're a real [ __ ] [ __ ] you in
everything you do just to have that just
out there
just written
that's that's really tremendous oh by
the way if you guys want to read
an unbelievable book i told you i was
reading that uh
that book that uh al jorgensen
from ministry wrote i just finished it
man i'm telling you some of the most
insane
[ __ ] stories
you're ever gonna read
i'll give you one line
one descriptive line
from one of the stories
was basically
he was talking about like he's basically
talking about three of the craziest
people he's ever met
and he was talking about this one
lunatic guy who met this luna chick
chick groupie
and the line was
he
he brought her into the bathroom
butt [ __ ] her and then flushed her
clothes down the toilet
that's the most [ __ ]
insane thing i've ever heard in my life
so then she comes walking out of the
bathroom she's like oh my god like
what's with your friend what am i
supposed to wear
so they took a tablecloth off a table
and they cut a hole in it and they made
a dress out of it
and then tied it off around the middle
and then she was just went on tour with
them
happy as a clamp
um all right that's me butchering that
story just imagine 200 and what was it
273 pages of that phenomenal
phenomenal [ __ ] read and it also
exposed me to all this amazing music in
the 80s that i completely missed on
because you know i was 12 in 1980
so right around
you know
i don't you know yeah
you don't listen to good music when
you're in your teenage years unless you
have really well-informed
older siblings like the youngest kid in
the family usually knows what to listen
to
you know if he has old you know brothers
who are like eight nine ten or sisters
that are old like eight years older or
something can usually help his friends
to hey you know
just some of the music that ministry was
making right
and to think that i was arguing with
people
about whether uh
you know motley crue was better than
poison not [ __ ] on those bands but
i'm just saying
because i like both those bands for what
they are i like them you know i love
motley crue and poison it took me a
while i mean they came out with makeup
and all the chicks liked them
and you know so it's you they were
easily hateable so was bon jovi and all
that oh my god he's so dreamy you know
oh those guys [ __ ] suck right
you just start doing that [ __ ] but if
you just look at them what the [ __ ] they
were doing you know it's all right right
but anyways i had no idea i had no
[ __ ] idea
and i still don't if you guys actually
you know you know a lot about that type
of music or you got some punk bands
because i missed out
on all of that [ __ ] and um
i'd really like to go back and listen
and work my way through that
um the road less traveled of 80s music
because
i didn't know any better all right okay
continuing on
what the [ __ ] is this
oh this is from last week
and of course i just reduced the damn
thing
and rather than uh is that the right
word reduced it
are you cooking here bill
um oh by the way all things comedy has
uh we're starting to do a monthly show
down at lago lago on los cienega um we
have a show um
this tuesday night all things comedy um
the podcast is on the network me and al
madrigal we're going to be down there
knocking out another show we had a great
time um
last month's show was one of the best
stand-up shows i've been on in a long
time just as far as not only the level
of comedy stand-up comedy just the
diverse
um
the the i know just it was a really
great mix
of comics that were on that one so we're
hoping we can do it again and uh it's
also a great
you know if you see how diverse the
comedians are so are the podcasts on all
things comedy and i really appreciate
everybody that's already bought tickets
so come on down it's gonna be eight
o'clock on tuesday night all right
plowing ahead
plowing ahead what else do we got here
oh you know what [ __ ] bugs me
i went to toronto again which is such a
great city they're all montreal toronto
vancouver
i just have a great time when i'm up
there and i can't wait to
run through that that country up there
in uh march of next year's when we're
shooting
to uh tour that country but uh every
time i go to toronto i always go
i got to go to the elma combo because
that's where stevie ray vaughan
uh he recorded that uh
i guess live at the alma cabo and i
[ __ ] still didn't get to do it this
time just didn't have enough goddamn
time it's annoying so anyways
let's plow ahead here uh mother teresa
is what this next one is called bill you
mentioned in your youtube tour of boston
something to the effect
of that someday someone is going to
write a tell-all about mother teresa
yeah i was just joking around
said someone did
here's the link
um here's a link to the documentary
based on the book
quick summary she was a [ __ ]
come on
a hundred percent
she wasn't uh she wasn't helped some
people out
jesus christ well you know what if
mother teresa can be called a [ __ ] i
guess i should take the fact that i'm a
real [ __ ]
you're a real [ __ ] you realize that
um all right college stadium
oh hey by the way anybody uh
anybody ever been to italy
um i'm gonna go there uh to get
acclimated to the time before i do the
european tour i'm just gonna i said [ __ ]
it you know why just go over there and
bang out a bunch of shows i never get to
see anything
um other than
the backs of comedy clubs i wanna go see
some [ __ ] so i've decided that i'm gonna
go over you know a couple two three days
over in italy and uh i'm leaning towards
going to naples
anybody anybody at all if you've ever
been there can you give me some places
to go i want to go see a [ __ ] opera
over there
get all dressed up bring a little
handkerchief cry like a little girl you
know
take the whole [ __ ] thing in have
some sketti
and then i'm off i'm off on my run so if
you guys have any suggestions i would
really appreciate it um
oh and speaking of which there's really
just a lot of announcements this week i
had a lot of [ __ ] happen thank you to uh
whoever brought me the uh
ken burns the war on dvd that was
ridiculously generous of you did not
have to do that and believe me i will be
uh
watching that once again the second i
get through all of ken burns's the rest
of them
because i've already seen that one but i
definitely want to watch it again
because it's like such a history lesson
just as far as you can just see
oh first we went here then we went here
this is where this island is this is
where the battle of the bulge was really
[ __ ]
fascinating so thank you for that um all
right college stadium
bill i am
a group of my buddies and i uh want to
take a trip somewhere random and catch a
good college football game not
necessarily just the game of the team
but also a great stadium we're all in
our mid-20s and live in florida been to
plenty of gators and seminoles games i
was going to say jesus christ well you
don't have to travel you got it right
there
which college college stadium would you
suggest we make our trip to somewhere
that serves beer during the game would
be a plus but not a requirement um i
don't know about i don't know that
the ncaa any of the college stadiums
serve beer um
i never noticed that they didn't at the
rose bowl because i was so [ __ ]
shit-faced
that i didn't need any more alcohol so i
never i'm usually trying to buy
something to absorb all the booze that
i've ingested
um
but um i don't think that you can't
that's what my friends have been telling
me we were just in college station and
um
they didn't sell it there they didn't
sell it at the lsu game so anyways in
other words what's the best college
stadium atmosphere that you've been to
that you would recommend visiting
i love the podcast blah blah blah go
[ __ ] yourself okay um yeah i like that
you phrased it that way because i'm only
going by
what i've done um
i gotta tell you lsu alabama
in baton rouge
was uh
even if you you're not a fan of the
sport you realize that you're at
something legendary and special just
sec football in general like the level
that's being played at they're in
another golden age of that conference
and i and i'm blown away
by how well behaved and polite the fans
are because you know the stereotype of
southerners you know walking around oh
what are you doing over here boy i'll
get out we don't lock your cat around
here
you know it's nothing like that
it's nothing most of that [ __ ] is just
from watching mississippi burning and
hollywood's version
i'm not saying that those guys don't
exist
all right
it's kind of like uh that ray donovan
character
like that character is supposed to
represent like everybody on the east
coast
basically the northeast that that's how
people are
you know
you come you come near my family again
and i'll [ __ ] kill you
you know that [ __ ] all the time and
like like everybody down south is
[ __ ] playing a washboard it's not
like that all at all i thought that they
were uh
you know they throw down the level even
college station they were amazing
um this is what i would do
i would pick if you're a fan of any
other team
going to a home game against one of
their big rivals is awesome it's it's
it's fun to go to a game where you
actually give a [ __ ] about the team
um so you kind of have a dog in the
fight or if you're going to uh uh go see
someone really special you know
like some
once in a generation kind of player like
johnny football comes around like you
know that that guy's gonna be a legend
regardless of what he does in the
football uh nfl whether he makes it or
not that's
to be able to say like i saw that guy in
his sophomore year
play against alabama
and uh in a 49-42 game that's pretty
cool so
if i was you
just to looking at saving money and that
type of [ __ ] you really don't need to go
anywhere you're down there in sec
country anyways i would go see
alabama i go to the alabama auburn game
even though auburn's not as good as they
were
uh with cam newton i'd go to one of
those once
for some reason the florida georgia game
in jacksonville does not interest me
because that it's an away game for
everybody because they were worried
about the behavior of people i want to
see their behavior i like when
there's one team going into
a hostile uh
hostile environment so
you know like i saw texas oklahoma at
the cotton bowl and that was awesome and
it was a great legendary stadium to go
to but there was definitely something
missing there was no you know you're in
our house now
vibe was not there um
so i don't know jesus am i [ __ ]
meandering this week or what
so if i was you i would either go to
tuscaloosa i'd go to baton rouge um
tennessee for some reason looks [ __ ]
insane to me
tennessee i think would be insane just
because that's in just
knoxville is just the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and there's nothing else to do
but to go absolutely ape [ __ ] at a
tennessee volunteers game and just watch
them throwing down i'm telling you half
the [ __ ]
show is being outside the stadium and
watching how hardcore
these people party
um or and cook and all that i mean they
don't get drunk and belligerent like uh
at least i haven't seen that yet there's
probably a lot of people rolling their
[ __ ] eyes but uh
you know it seems like the violent fans
are on the coasts
i don't know like if you got to get
stomped or [ __ ] stabbed or shot
especially out here in california
um
i don't know and if you mosey on up to
somebody's smoker all you do throw them
a couple of compliments next thing you
know you got something smoked sitting on
a plate they'll [ __ ] hook you up
they're great they're great people
southgate the south gets such a bad
[ __ ] reputation and i know there's a
racism and there's all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but unfortunately that racism
is everywhere at least as far as my
travels so uh the end of the day those
[ __ ] cook better than they do in up
north at a football game anyways
so there you go there's my long-winded
[ __ ]
answer all right hey billy bats
couple weeks ago you said you don't want
to see the colosseum because it's too
touristy i implore you to change your
mind oh here it is
uh you yourself
you oh you owe yourself you left out the
o
what you you yourself love to go to
different arenas and stadiums in america
if i remember correctly you said you
wanted to go to every major sporting
arena in the u.s yeah i know this
argument i know what you mean as well as
major college stadiums the colosseum is
one of the oldest stadiums in the world
and the most famous in history in the
history of the world 50 000 people could
sit in it
it had a retractable roof giant pieces
of fabric that were controlled
by men to block the sun out
jesus christ all right i'm sold i'm
going and some historical texts claim
that it was even filled with water
and naval battles were reenacted for the
public
jesus christ you know what
was was that the greatest empire of all
time
wow they put the gluttony
even even you know i can only speak for
my country but even like the level of
big gulps and how fat people are now
even with that we don't have puking
rooms here
like they had rooms the romans had rooms
just for like after you've gorged
yourself where you just went in and
yacked
you know
and can you imagine the poor conquered
people
that had to clean that [ __ ] thing out
every couple hours
[Laughter]
an unair conditioned puke room wow
jesus christ i'd fight a line in a
second not to [ __ ] have to do that
just get it over with um he said yes it
is very a very touristy place to go but
it is the most famous arena in the
history of the world it was built nearly
2000 years
ago and still stands today i guarantee
you that eyesore in dallas won't be
standing in 2000 years p.s my girlfriend
watched your episode of new girl and
said it was the first time she ever saw
you not yelling
[Laughter]
jesus i'm getting pounded this week but
i can't i can't argue any of it
i am a real [ __ ] and i do scream a lot
um
all right well maybe maybe i i'll do
that like look i have i have plans of uh
for the rest of my stand up career of of
continuing to expand my tours
through your through europe and uh
wherever else they'll have me australia
and
i want to see it man i'm only here once
i want to see it and uh
italy i don't plan on just going to one
time like there's all these different
through all these years of watching uh
mario batali um who gets my vote is the
coolest [ __ ] redhead on tv
all right
um
just his knowledge and passion
for uh that country and their food
and all the different places to go
um he's made me want to go to so many
different parts of italy so i'm just
starting
with this one i guess i should start
with rome but it just seemed hacky
to go there so uh
i don't know i mean the game plan always
was to tour make a little bit of money
in europe and then blow all of it
in some awesome country so
that's basically it i probably won't be
making that much money
in europe because people don't really
know me and uh but you know how much
does spaghetti cost
[Laughter]
all right how about a little advertising
here all right e-voice everyone if
you're an entrepreneur and a customer
calls do you want it to seem like you're
in a high-rise window view fancy-pants
office or do you want them to know that
you're just sitting there in your
underwear in a one-bedroom apartment
you know all sweaty on a futon that's
not good for business what do you do if
you can't afford the high-rise go to
e-voice with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building sales
customer support tech support you name
it it's gonna seem like you got it give
your customers the royal treatment with
e-voice e-voice will forward your
business calls to your home mobile or
any number you choose wherever you are
e-voice will find you don't have time to
take a call no biggie it's routed as any
uh is routed to to your voicemail and
you can read it at your convenience as
an email e-voice not only gives you an
edge over your competition it will take
away the edge the big companies have
over you right now and now you can try
e-voice for free for 30 days go to
evoice.com or just go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner that's e-voice everybody
and finally legalzoom a lot of pride
comes along with starting your dream
business doesn't it
heart swells up a little tear in your
eye you push it back down because you're
a man you're not allowed to cry and if
you're a woman you feel like you're
competing against men
right so you got to push it down or
maybe you don't i don't know but anyways
either way this works for both people
both sexes male female hermaphrodite
legalzoom everyone
let's get back to the copy shall we but
think about the stress you'll feel if
you don't take the right steps to
legally protect your business and
personal assets from the beginning
that's why i me billy redface recommend
legalzoom.com during the past 12 years
over a million business owners have
trusted legalzoom to help start their
own businesses legalzoom will save you a
lot of time and a pile of money on
startup costs plus they'll provide
solutions to help you run a successful
business legalzoom can provide self-help
services at your specific direction or
connect you with an attorney but they
are not a law firm
just go to legalzoom.com today to see
what's right for you form an llc get a
dba incorporate or form a non-profit all
starting at just 99
plus you'll save even more when you
enter bur burr and the referral box at
check checkout that's legalzoom.com
promo code burr one more time
legalzoom.com promo code
burr there we go
bill here is a dilemma you're hanging
out your house wanting a snack your lady
says she's going to bake you some
cookies what a sweetheart absolutely
what a champ
um she brings the cookies out and to
your surprise
they are dick-shaped cookies
think bachelorette party complete with
sprinkles for pubes etc
you're hungry and the cookies are sure
to be tasty but they are shaped like
dicks
do you eat all the cookies
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
uh you know what we have here sir
that right there is a classic example of
some cold lotion
that right there
is some [ __ ] cold lotion you said
you're hungry you want a snack
and your woman goes i'll go make you
some cookies you're like holy [ __ ]
i finally found a woman that still cooks
it doesn't feel like uh you're taking
away her right to vote if she goes out
and does that for you phenomenal she
brings the cookies in you're all excited
and you look down and you got a bowl of
[ __ ]
um
do you eat the cookies
well do you plan to run for office
someday sir
if you do
well that probably wouldn't work i would
say you should take a picture of
yourself eating the bowl of dicks
that way
no one could ever say that you're
homophobic
but somebody could run a smear campaign
and say that your marriage was a sham
and just have you you know they picked
the worst picture you with your eyes
half clothes and the most enjoyable
ecstasy look in your face sugar rush as
you're sticking a dick in your mouth i
know that could go either way
do you eat the cookies
um
hey listen man a [ __ ] cookie's a
cookie i'd eat them if they tasted good
um
hey when those things get stale does
that mean they're kind of they get like
erect sorry that was a stupid dick joke
um
do you eat the cookies i don't know
about you know what i'd have to know
what you if your girlfriend did that to
be [ __ ] hilarious like hey you want
some cookies and then comes out with a
bowl of dicks
dick cookies that's [ __ ] hilarious at
which point i'd eat all of them
but uh yeah there's no way she wasn't
trying to be funny you know what you
should laugh and you should eat them
with a big glass of milk which uh
metaphorically is jizz color
if you get like the zero percent fat you
should just go all out with it
ah that's [ __ ] gross i never like sex
jokes with food isn't that disgusting
did i groce you out i apologize i
apologize to you on this wonderful
monday hey by the way everybody i bet
you sitting there going like you know
[ __ ] my life i want to know what bill's
doing this weekend i know you're not but
let's just just
appease my ego
appease the ego of a real [ __ ] here
um i'm gonna be at the chicago the
legendary chicago theater
this uh
this saturday night for not one but two
shows who am i bringing along none other
than masterchef slash rose bowl tailgate
legend jason lawhead whose cleveland
browns won this week
all right so check out lawhead court lie
heads court his uh his podcast
um you'll get to hear something that you
haven't heard in a long time which is
probably a happy cleveland browns fan
um i am a closet cleveland browns fan
because i think they have one of the
best [ __ ] uniforms
in the league and uh
and they were great when i was a kid in
the 80s i loved those bronze teams that
[ __ ] municipal stadium
just that it just was on nfl films
municipal stadium when it was overcast
and it was cold and it maybe snowed a
little bit now the field was muddy
that just would it was one of the last
great
football stadiums out there even though
i know it was built for baseball was
probably a terrible place to see a game
in a lot of ways
um
i was a fan of brian sipe and the
cardiac kids and all of that [ __ ] so i
always root for those [ __ ]
um
so anyways yeah i'll be at the uh the
chicago theater unfortunately i'm
coming in and coming right back out
flying in the day of and then leaving i
wanted to try and
maybe take in i think northwestern's at
home i know notre dame is at home i'm
just going to try to drive over there
but i think it's too long to [ __ ]
drive but uh
anyways if you guys have any suggestions
on a great place to eat i don't want to
get deep dish pizza um
i don't do that how about more like a
steak place that deep dish pizza man
like
you always order one you're like i got
this i got this and it becomes like a
man versus food moment
um it is
it is delicious do you know what [ __ ] it
how about a steak place and a good place
to get a deep dish pizza you know what
you guys should do you guys should try
to see how [ __ ] fat you can make me
just subtly
just all get together like that guy
suggested like you're all in
communication with each other
you know and now that i've canceled
those dates why don't you guys try to
get together and decide to make me a fat
freckled [ __ ]
um all right
hater
all right billy tit rag
i don't know what what is a tit wreck
is that a worn out bra
um i i need some advice on a hater
all right i'm 20 years old
hey that guy called it
that guy who called me a ginger scumbag
he called it that's at least he called
the age that somebody 20 years old was
going to write it i'm 20 years old and
i've been pretty shy and self-conscious
for my entire life until recently that's
understandable sir
i was well within the tortoise shell
until i was 23.
um he says i've started to just say [ __ ]
it it doesn't matter what anyone else
thinks that's a great thing good for you
he said and it feels great but it's hard
though i'm no expert i got a lot i've
got a lot more confidence and now
i've i had i now have one of my first
haters
well that's good
you know what most people hate
most people hate watching somebody enjoy
themselves or be successful
so
he must
either he knew you or she knew you
before when you were shy and now is
seeing you starting to come out coming
to your own and it's making that person
feel left behind or
uh they're just straight across the
board anybody having a good time and
enjoying themselves they try to knock
them down
um anyways he says this kid goes to my
college of 600 people we go out as a big
group most nights and he's always there
once in a while he'll throw a comment my
way and i just ignore it
last night i was talking to a girl and
he comes up behind and puts my hood over
my head i turned around and stared at
him for 10 seconds and he just looked
away this kid's pathetic i've just been
ignoring him and trying not to give a
[ __ ] that doesn't work with bullying sir
that doesn't um he says i definitely
don't want to fight the kid and ruin my
reputation but i also don't want to look
like a little [ __ ] i figured you might
know what to say seeing that you deal
with hecklers all the time thanks um
first of all hey you don't have to hang
out with this kid
um
you know this unfortunately this is not
the first one of these kinds of people
that's going to be in your life you have
to
um
you got to pay attention especially when
you're younger
because you're kind of wide open
because you just you know you're just
out of your parents house you starting
to learn [ __ ] on your own and a lot of
times if you came from a dysfunctional
home you'll actually surround yourself
with the same kind of [ __ ] the exact
country when you yelled at your parents
i'm out of here you're never gonna see
me again [ __ ] this and you walk out you
actually end up rebuilding that exact
same structure now that's not my that's
obviously i've heard that you know from
people who are intelligent and
i actually went out and did that so what
you have to do you got to cut the cancer
out all right you don't need to be
around this guy you're having a good
time you're coming into your own you're
talking to the ladies you're having a
good time
so uh
no if he does something like that to you
again yeah you gotta you have to at some
point you gotta step to the kid and just
be like dude is there some sort of a
problem here
you know
and considering you just stared at him
and he looked away i i pretty much think
he's gonna back down
but uh you know if you gotta do what you
gotta do if you gotta have a fight you
gotta have a fight it's not a bad thing
you know
this nowadays with lawsuits and all
these
youtube videos and [ __ ] kids used to
settle [ __ ] amongst themselves
so uh you might have to do that i hope
you don't
um but yeah i i would not ignore him
i would not ignore him i would uh you
know if you don't want to go the
physical route i would just pick out
something
um that looks bad on him physically and
i would bring that up
i would go i would go right for the
[ __ ] jugular
uh with that kid
there's a zillion different ways to do
it and i'm afraid to tell you which way
to do it because if it goes wrong then
you know the way everybody gets sued
nowadays just know i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but um
i do know that if you're gonna keep
running into the same person and they're
they're they're overstepping a boundary
with you ignoring them does not make
them go away
you know like that [ __ ] they say if you
run into a black bear just stand still
and ignore it it'll go away that they
don't okay
so you have to uh you got to address it
he could say anything
anything to him whatever his name is hey
what's up you're gonna be in a [ __ ]
mood again this night
you know
can you do me a favor maybe rub one out
before you come over here with your
frustrated [ __ ] energy something like
that i don't know except don't start it
when you say energy
energy
uh i don't know i don't know if you know
how to fight if you know how to fight uh
you know
i'm not saying to do it but uh
there is a reason god allowed you to
ball up your fist
hey if god didn't want us to punch
anybody in the face
would he have blessed us with fists
is that amazing thing about your hand
how he can caress somebody or [ __ ]
choke him to death
just the options that's why i don't
think he's he's going to judge you you
can [ __ ] really do whatever you want
you know
you're going to [ __ ] just give people
the the the
i've been doing a bit about this how you
can give people freedom a choice
and then you're going to get upset when
they make the wrong choices
you're going to make them flawed and
then you're going to get mad
i don't understand that
i really don't all right anyways that's
the podcast for this week everybody i
hope you had a good time uh just to let
you know this week once again i'm going
to be in chicago theater and then i have
uh after that and i could i can tell you
one guy who's not going to be there
that guy from earlier uh this week i
lost one everybody
he's not even listening to this right
now
um
anyways you know what i should get the
email the guy from the past week who got
all pissed off about the el paso one i
got to get that from my guy
uh who helps me with all this [ __ ] i
should let him know that it's been
rescheduled that he can get his money
back and all that i still feel bad that
he drove four hours i knew that was
going to [ __ ] happen
anyways here we go
um
october 3rd i'm going to be october 2nd
the rescheduled show in el paso is going
down
it's going down all right
and i will try to do something extra
special to make up for the fact that all
these people drove out there and then it
[ __ ] rained which was beyond my
control
and uh you know it's [ __ ] up i had
such a good time driving from el paso to
uh san antonio that i think i'm actually
gonna drive from la to el paso it's a
12-hour drive which is uh that's nothing
that's nothing to uh i've been doing the
road for a long time i already know how
i'm going to break it up break it up see
break it up
uh all right
october 3rd i'll be at the san jose
center for the performing arts october
4th paramount theater in seattle
washington we are the loudest um
october 5th i'll be at the celebrity
theater in phoenix arizona
that is in the round all of those are
going to be uh
just amazing venues and just really
going to be
fun shows i got all this new [ __ ] that i
i've been working on a bunch of stuff is
coming together i'm excited to be doing
my act so i'm thrilled that you guys are
coming out
um despite the fact that i'm a real [ __ ]
all right there you go and that's the
podcast here's the wrap up everybody now
that the show is over do me a favor uh
don't forget to go to uh my podcast page
and if you're gonna go to amazon and buy
something if you'd like to help out this
podcast and the warriors project just
click on the amazon banner it doesn't
cost you any extra money they kicked me
a little uh
little uh thanks a lot little how's your
father there and uh then i kicked part
of that over to the wounded warriors
project everybody [ __ ] wins
um
and that's it and the rumor has it that
the podcast t-shirts are done and then
i'm going to be picking them up this
week
so
get ready for those for next week and
lastly but not leastly
not leastly don't forget to sign up for
your free trial of hulu plus
hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of
tits shows anytime anywhere tv pc
smartphone or tablet
it's uh it's awesome man support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of hulu plus when you go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
hulu plus banner or go to huluplus.com
bill that's huluplus.com
bill once again thank you to everybody
listen to this podcast have a great week
go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next monday
you